hi and welcome to episode number 37 of
the weekly Google apart from podcast I
am Francis Campo and I'm here with my
colleague mark Mandel hey Mark hey
friends sku doing very good happy to
have Kotter back for one more week
episode I'd like you to be like yeah
well down today just a very happy person
in general yeah yeah so yeah we're gonna
have cutter to keep on telling us about
kubernetes 1.3 but specifically about
the new things are coming to Google
container engine container waiting with
okay so gke yeah so we got a whole bunch
of new features and new stuff above and
beyond what already came with 1.3 in
communities so we're gonna have a chat
about that and they're some pretty cool
stuff in there yeah and also during the
interview we will also mention like how
do you get started with kubernetes what
are the best ways to learn the basics
and etc so regardless of you if you are
an expert that wants to know more about
the latest things or if you want to
really learn the basics I think this
interview will be very good for you
absolutely and then at the end we will
have a question of the week and for the
second maybe third I don't count any
more week in a row the question will be
on kubernetes
yeah well it's such an interesting topic
I just kind of avoid it I know now
people keep on asking questions about
career ideas which is which is great
very happy to answer all of those and I
keep on learning by answering them so
yay yeah so we're gonna have a little
chat about how we do local development
with kubernetes
yep but before that we're gonna start
with a cool thing of the week and the
cool thing of the week this week comes
from you and it comes clearly from you
because it involves your favorite
favorite intellect which is what is the
name again deployment manager the
Florian manager could go cloud
deployment manager and it is related to
ma at the B so the question is okay so I
want to I want to run mommy to be on
Google cloud platform yep what is the
easiest / best way to get started so
this is this is actually quite
interesting so there are a few ways that
you could create MongoDB on Google cloud
platform obviously you could fire up
your compute engine instances and sort
of manually install it to it that way
not necessarily a difficult way to do it
we have Google cloud launcher to quickly
create and sort of test among gray to be
replica set that works but to a degree
like it's a little hard to manage once
it's already up like if you want to
upgrade it becomes a little bit more
difficult it's not not like that however
what we have and there's a blog post
that comes along with this that goes
that is on Google cloud platforms blog
that provisions and installs MongoDB
cloud manager which is a MongoDB -
MongoDB tool for for running and running
a replica set of MongoDB in the cloud
but we use cloud deployment manager
templates to basically bootstrap that
and keep that up and running and get
that up and started so you kind of get
the best of both worlds you get almost
you know sort of the the speed and
simplicity of using say like cloud
launcher but you know now you've got
something that's managed by MongoDB it's
it's hooked into this services and then
so if you want to run MongoDB in the
cloud it seems like a really nice way to
do it a production it at scale cool that
sounds very cool and and yeah the the
blog post will be linked from the show
notes as always great so I think it is
time to go back to our long interview
with Connor Morgan so he keeps on
letting us know more about gke 11.3
absolutely I don't think we've talked to
him in a long time let's go for that so
since we enjoyed last week so much
talking to Cara Morgan we back again to
talk about our kubernetes and DK hiker
how are you doing doing well Francis
long time no see like I never left
yeah so for those that didn't listen to
the previous episode we discussed a
little bit about all the new things that
come with communities 103 and one of
those things was like more nodes and
like bigger things and all of those
things and it was all related to just
like kubernetes in the wild you can run
you want to run it and come gcg ke but
also now amazona wherever you want to
run it today we're gonna be talking more
specifically about GAE so what what is
there it's just the first question could
be is kubernetes 103 available on gk yep
I just updated all my clusters last
night so I can test out all the new
features it's available for everybody if
you don't know GK is Google container
engine that's a C which is weird because
they had the name taken but it's it's
it's a hosted version of kubernetes so
they're basically hosts a master for you
on Google compute instances you don't
get charged for that and you just get
charged for compute instances you use
cool so other than old and new features
in one the three that will be available
on gke what all the things are are we
expecting to have yeah so there's a lot
of container engine specifics now
there's things like the new container VM
images so what that is is a more secure
stripped-down image so since it's
stripped down there's less places for
attackers to get at it comes with auto
updates it's just basically optimized
for a container environment
so before concuss ters we're running i
think goes debian so if i fire up in
your gke cluster now this is gonna run
this new this new image or whatever you
have to select it okay and then I think
they're all prefix GCI so you can tell
the difference when you look up I
forgive an exact command off the top my
head but they're prefixed CCI for the
ones and this is in beta but it's one of
those features that I think again more
security more better right yeah so these
gonna make anything about basically like
Mike were not unique kernels we had an
episode on that and not that long ago so
the idea is that you're gonna be
removing things like like FTP and like
the services that are actually not
related to kubernetes is that the main
idea or it's a basic idea so you're
saying what do I need to run containers
what do containers do often let's keep
that okay let's get rid of the rest and
if you need if you need those back in
apt-get install good still work or you
know I haven't checked the specific okay
so I'm not sure what they restrict okay
that's
okay but at least then you know it sort
of limits limits attacks vectors for
security makes it easier to update for
the Google cloud team and probably makes
their lives a whole lot easier
across-the-board right and then it also
comes with auto updating features so as
new security fixes come in you'll get
that updated automatically to your
cluster very cool cool what else other
than container VM images I've heard
about SSDs there's a lot of people
excited about that they need more speed
yeah yeah so in DKA NGC you you have
local SSD so you can use those now they
just just go a lot faster
you just get this days it's good it's
all good there yeah I'm imagining that
with the pet sets and local sustain I if
you want to run things like big
databases on kubernetes it will be much
faster than before so I know we've had a
really big push internally around like I
am and like access control I know they
were senior authorization
facilities that were in place with
kubernetes is that there's that been
extended to I am now as well right so
they added role based access or are back
and now with I am in GK what you get is
all the API calls now you can say okay
who has access to do this who can start
up the new pod who can you can delete
stuff so that's support in gke now what
I am is is identity and access
management so that's really cool I mean
when you're running a really large team
especially if you have a really large
cluster you want to have control over
who can do what within that cluster I
think that sounds really really powerful
and really useful well so the coolest
thing about I am is that instead of
instead of like role-based of reset it
you know I have an admin and admin can
do everything I have a user he can do
three things now you can get a lot more
granular so I can say mark can you know
create clusters francese can delete them
in me Carter I can do everything yeah
yeah that doesn't make sense
I wouldn't I wouldn't to have the power
to delete clusters that sounds scary a
lot of responsibility a lot of Richmond
I don't need that kind of responsibility
in my life so also related to this when
you when you say role based access we
talked about people but is it also I
have
good practice like security or practice
to say oh you like this instance know
these kind of instances have access to
these a part of the API but not others
or is that is it something that you've
seen I haven't seen it I haven't seen it
so I don't want to comment on best
practices okay I know that you can set
up service accounts and say who can
access what go hub and so somehow
someone in your organization it would
set that up nice all right I know you
were getting quite excited about node
fools yes okay I really I really like
node fools
so what no pools are is kind of like
cluster Federation light so one of the
things you can have instead of having
different clusters here you can have
different node polls that can be
replicated across zones
so with cluster Federation like we
talked about last week
you could have clusters in different
regions like Asia Europe u.s. you can
also have them across different cloud
providers like AWS GCP or even on-prem
like OpenStack here what you're gonna
get is something replicated across zones
so if you're worried that his own might
fail so it's very its lightweight it's
not and it's not the same as a cluster
Federation but what you can also do is
have different types of nodes in your
cluster so I could say maybe I have a
database and I want 200 gigabyte machine
for it to sit on so if you'd if that
data but my front-end application or my
server app only needs like a 10 gig
pretty small instance so now I can do
that that's that's very powerful and I
take it you've got control there as well
in terms of where your pods end up
sitting within that node pole mm-hmm
yeah so there's there's affinity and you
can also use selectors so you could say
basically when you use node pools that
you get a label attached to the node
it's an actual machine and you can use
that in your pod to select which one
it's going to sit on
now that sounds that sounds super useful
being able to like specifically say hey
you know this container should be on
this type of thing now to play devil's
advocate a little bit does that go
against the idea of kettle versus pets
or is that still in the same like kettle
category I think when you have
persistent data you no longer have
cattle because data matters data isn't
stateless right so maybe the whole idea
of persistent data goes against cattle
okay
instead of something to consider when
dealing with no tools and how you
sure stuff yeah that's a great question
yeah their pros and cons yeah I wonder
if having note poles plus having local
assist these is something that can make
it like you can say you know I was like
all my web servers are gonna be running
on like the the light
no it's but then I have the notes with
local is they're gonna be running
whatever it to be or whatever database
you want to use it sounds like a good
good thing to have yeah it sounds like a
perfect use case yeah nice something
else related also to note no it's none
not pools
it is note auto-scaling yes I've seen
these many times before
and it was like you need to make it you
need to write your own Auto skater it
was quite hard seems like we fixed that
and we have it now as a part of
kubernetes a pile of GK GK yeah ng C so
basically now there was already
horizontal pata scaling so if you used
up too many resources on pod you could
scale up a pod that was built into
kubernetes what what is for our
listeners what is horizontal scaling
versus vertical scaling good question
good question so horizontal scaling is
scaling up more instances of your
application whereas vertical scaling is
scaling up more resources for your
instances to live on so now in gke what
you get is vertical auto scaling so we
can say I have this pod that I can't
schedule right now because there's not
enough space for it GK is smart enough
or compute is smart enough to go and
look and say if I were to add another
node could I schedule this pot and if so
then schedule it nice and so there's a
there's a few use cases for this
actually if you think about it taking a
CI service continuous integration it's
gonna be really busy Monday through
Friday if you're not one of those
companies that's making people work all
weekend and it's gonna wind down on the
weekend so why waste money having all
these resources up over the weekend yeah
you can have your work your notes scale
up while everyone's in there working and
then over the weekend wind back down
save your money
yeah thatthat sounds like very very good
use of your money I'm wondering how does
this work with again stateful apps okay
yeah hmm I know there's some things that
are still getting ironed out like we
just talked about node affinity or using
node selectors yeah well so if I add a
label or if
other cubes detail commands to a note
that's not gonna get replicated when I
scale up a pot or not mm-hmm so if
you're using that to say I want my note
to sit on this pod because it's SSD and
I want it to go fast and in this state
full reason that's not gonna work I
suppose that makes sense to like if
you're like order scaling at least right
now especially like if your order
scaling out a cluster it's for mostly
stateless apps I mean that's the stuff
you really want to grow and shrink down
it's not for stuff that's like yeah like
growing a shrinking a database in real
time it makes me really scared yeah are
people that grow in string databases I
don't know I mean I'm pretty sure you
can like I know that for for BigTable
you can totally do that
it is not auto scaling though mm-hmm but
you need to be quite careful because if
you have like your data is replicated on
three nodes yeah it needs to be
replicated on three nodes and you turn
down like all of those three nodes that
happen to have one single key mm-hmm
then you lose data which is bad so I'm
sure you can do it but you need to be
really careful yeah the sort of thing
that'll be like okay I'm happy doing
this on a manual way but I don't want
like a machine doing it at least not yet
yeah so what what what are your like
what is your advice for people that
would like to run maybe like some like
let's say something typical like
WordPress and you have like the front
end and then you have the database where
could you put the database like I I
could personally avoid putting in
containers but I don't use containers
all the time what is your opinion on
that I think if I could host a database
I would this this is my most candid
opinion as in I'd use like a my sequel
service or something like that that's
hosted instead of putting it in a
container but with the new features in
kubernetes I think we're gonna see a lot
more experimentation a lot more people
trying it out so maybe new best
practices are gonna emerge
okay so maybe maybe the tooling is not
quite there yet but as people start to
play with it it'll sort of it'll get
there at a certain point right yeah we
talked about the thousand node Cassandra
demo and again you know it's a demo so
we didn't see it in production we're
gonna see how long it lasts but that's
really exciting to me because if you can
scale up from scale
like that with kubernetes that's almost
like using a hosted service so I don't
know if it's a release away or if it's
ready right now I want to go play in
after this and check it out actually
combining that with stuff like what's
the packing the package manager for
communities cold these days helm is it
helmets change names about three or four
times I think but being able to sit
around and say hey I want Cassandra boom
you know I want a MongoDB replica said
boom the combination of that and those
two things I think that's that is quite
powerful yeah
and so again crew net is supposed to be
a pluggable framework like that
so I could see that happening in the
future exciting time to be working on
kubernetes yeah so there's a lot of
really fancy new things going around but
I feel like there's also one many of our
listeners are still curious about ok so
I've never used kubernetes where do I
get started yeah I'm seeing that a lot
especially like going to conference
isn't giving it talk yes there is always
a big crowd of people that are like oh
we want to know more
to that end Kelsey and I made a course
Udacity scalable micro services the
kubernetes it goes over everything from
ok I have an application how do i
package and distribute that in a docker
image what are some best practices for
that so we talked about things like 12
factor the micro services pattern which
is the most overused term and all of
them containers we talk about the basics
of kubernetes like so deployment
services health and monitoring secrets
and all that and then we get a little
bit more event and talk about deployment
patterns and rolling updates and things
like that so that would be my first
choice I'm a little biased there you
know that's fair enough
we've got interviews with really
intelligent people like Adrian Cockcroft
former cloud architect on Netflix and he
talks about the pet first cattle divided
a little bit as well and the importance
of infrastructure why you would use it
when the write your own if ever things
like that that sounds really cool does
it cover any of the cluster set up side
of things so we its foreign application
developers right and so that's the one
of the things I'm learning is a in this
role I'm a I'm a DP so my role is
meeting customer zero and so I've got to
stop
using gke and things like that I've got
to start doing kubernetes the hard way
right yeah it makes it too easy for you
right so in this course that we wanted
to make it easy so what we did is we
used container engine which is the
easiest way to use kubernetes it's it's
pretty much one one one command line
you're ready to go and we also use cloud
shell which is what is it it's a
provision VM for you that keeps your dot
files you have a local space on a disk
somewhere it's a standard operating
environment so it's probably the easiest
way to get started with kubernetes is
cloud shell and koona in google google
container engine yeah that way
everything you need is just half having
browser that's it mm-hmm yeah so it was
it was a pretty nice pretty clean set up
we did missile there's a few things in
the course that if we were doing a
community tool one we would do like you
know more production use cases stateful
applications namespaces automatic
integration with the CIA tool continuous
integration continuous deployment so uh
but yeah if you want to get started that
course is the easiest quickest way to do
it it's a free course Udacity and Google
is that is that a teaser that you're
actually going to do it to everyone like
an advanced course because we're now
excited about it you know I really do
want to do more advanced workshops so
Nick Iglesias from the solutions team
put out a really great solution for
using Jenkins in in gke together so we
ran that as a workshop and people loved
it they absolutely ate it up
I guess if people are looking for that
advanced contact they can through emails
or comments to the episode and we'll
make sure to pass them on to Carter yeah
107 cool so we're kind of running out of
time for this episode is there anything
else that you'd like to mention about
kubernetes or gke that we had not
mentioned in these epitopes episode or
the previous one I guess just a wrap-up
uh you know kubernetes makes use claims
it says planet-scale never outgrow and
run anywhere and with 1.3 we're closer
to that than ever because you can run
anywhere with cluster Federation planets
scale 2,000 node 60,000 containers and
never outgrow you can go from you know
local to
again mm note so kubernetes is something
that you can get started with now trying
it out really easily with gke and cloud
shell and then you know take it on Prem
and err do whatever you really need to
do to meet production needs it's there
for you great well thanks so much for
joining us today thanks for having me
yep thank you well thanks so much so
gutter for spending not one but two
episodes with us and telling us
everything we needed to know but Carina
is one two three and container engine
we're gonna go through the question of
the week and and surprisingly it is also
but kubernetes is it really yeah
shocking right I know yeah so I think
done from from you what why don't you
yeah so this is a question I've heard a
lot from a bunch of people using
kubernetes it's really around how do I
do local development with kubernetes we
talked a little bit about on the podcast
as well like sitting up what clusters a
little bit difficult yeah there seems to
have been some options out there but
there's a few of them which one do I
choose what do I do
so if I want to do local development
communities how do I do it okay that's a
great question MIDI cube is the way to
go so what mini cube does is it sets you
up a local one node cluster using a VM
so by default it's VirtualBox but you
can specify different ones and then you
have a lot of the power of kubernetes
you don't get everything you don't get
ingress controllers you don't get load
balancers but for most of your like
day-to-day use on a single node machine
you can try it out and then you can take
that and just go and run the same thing
that you're running locally on a
provider so I know in previous local
versions of communities like I was
limited by the number of pods I could
run like I couldn't run more than like
say one part of a particular thing is
that limitation still in place with mini
cube or am I just kind of resource
controlled based on how big my VM is or
anything else you're going to the node
now so you have one node okay so I can
run multiples of those containers within
that node and very similar to what I
would run at scale but maybe just
slightly smaller mm-hmm and now mini
cube is ongoing so it's not like the
final finished product I'll stop my head
I can't remember whether they're
thinking about adding but again you
don't get like say the load balancer
or ingress but you can set up
deployments you know and all the all the
good stuff all the good stuff all the
good stuff but there's more stuff coming
and they're really like that that's the
one true way of doing local development
ooh we have some contention well no I
just I always get nervous when you when
you save one true way to do anything for
now for now freddie's wants to be so
open but if I was gonna do local
development right now and what I've been
playing with myself is many cute that's
right so thanks again to Cara Morgan to
spend with us two long episodes
kubernetes and gke and not only that but
also staying to answer the question of
the week today yeah absolutely
thanks so much for that yeah good job
mini cubes so cool cool so we go we're
about to finish but before finishing I
would like to remind our listeners on
how they can send the cool things of the
week or if they have any other questions
or proposals for topics we're also very
interesting that yep so if they want to
reach us by email where can they reach
us it is hello TCB podcast come our
website is it is either cheesy podcast
come or club the good luck um slash
podcast nice they want to speak to us on
reddit it is on the subreddit our slash
GCP podcast excellent if they want to
reach us on twitter it is a TCP podcast
yep if I want to reach us on Google+ it
is plus gzi podcast and the channel name
and the GCP slack community is podcast
yes there you go
I was like I'm really sure but that was
it yep wonderful well friends I thank
you again for joining me this week thank
you and talk to you all next week see
you next week